[Music]
zachary is on the line to start off this
hour in virginia hi zachary how are you
good how about you better than i deserve
what's up
sweet uh i know this is you've probably
gotten this question multiple times in
different
variants and it's probably nowhere near
to the degree but
i recently ended up getting into a car
loan which
honey potted me basically and what i
wanted to do was get a source of
transportation
to get a better job i'm 20 years old i
work two jobs about 70 to 75 hours a
week
and it originally was a good deal
and then as i got roped into it i ended
up
i now end up having to pay double what
the original price was
due to the interest and everything like
that and so i don't know whether it's a
good idea to
drop both jobs drop a job try and find
something better get cushioning
all along those lines i just don't know
what the best course of action is
[Music]
so what do you owe on the car what's the
payoff on it today
uh it would be seventeen thousand
dollars what's that what did you pay for
the car
i paid two thousand dollars down payment
uh this was literally about
the price that you paid for the car
nineteen thousand
uh it was seventeen thousand i got a car
loan
for up two thousand dollars it
originally was priced at nine thousand
dollars before
processing fees interested all that type
stuff
and then overall the card payments all
add up to seventeen thousand dollars no
that is not your payoff honey
that's the total of all your payments
yeah
okay that's not your payoff your payoff
is if you paid it off today
it would not be 17 000 that you owe that
includes
all the interest over the whole term of
the loan
and so if you paid it off today it's
more like ten thousand dollars okay
so what would be the best course of
action because i just downpaymented it
and i'm just looking at who do you who
do you owe the money to
uh timeless motorsports and what is the
uh so they carried the lot they carried
the note on the lot
yeah okay call them and ask them what
the payoff is
today that you want to pay it off
okay okay and get that and get that
number
and then figure out what the car is
worth
gotcha okay so let's say that that
number is ten
thousand and then you look the car up on
kelly bluebook
kbb.com and and let's say the car's
value if you sell it private sale if you
sell it to another individual which is
the best
you know your best pricing rather than
selling it to a dealer on a trade in
value
look up private sale on kelly blue book
and let's say that that's
nine thousand dollars and the payoff is
ten thousand dollars
well that means in order to sell it you
have to put a thousand dollars
extra on the table to pay off and get
out of this mess
yeah and then it sounds like you need to
sell the car doesn't it
it does i just don't know if it would
equal out to the
you know amount of like the total car
payments and everything that's what made
me there
it's not the total car payments yeah
okay the total car payments don't matter
unless you keep the car
and the loan through the whole term
that's the only way you're going to pay
17
000. yeah so do you have an interest
rate on this thing
yeah 25
okay um are are you living at home with
your parents
yeah okay was your father or mother
involved at all
no their their debt was too bad no i
mean
did they look at this situation with you
did no one say yeah
25 is brain damage
nobody said anything if anything i did i
was told it was normal
okay i'll help you with this it's brain
damage it's not even normal
car payments are fairly normal 25
interest on a car is not normal
yeah really really cray-cray okay
that's where you are all right so yeah
you got to get rid of this car
and this or get rid of this loan one of
the two
what are you earning yeah how much are
you earning uh uh with both jobs it's
about
2800 to all together to play around with
okay
and you can you live at home
uh yeah okay so what are your expenses
if you just said i'm going to live on
nothing and pay this car off very very
fast
uh i'd pay about i could probably triple
the car payments no you make 2 800.
what in the world would you be spending
money on you live at home
yeah uh food and everything like that
food where you live at home
groceries you have to buy groceries at
your house
yeah i ship them you chip in how much
uh about 200 okay 200. that leaves me
2600.
what other expenses do you have uh i do
give about another yeah and party
yeah okay so no restaurants
no life until you get this car paid off
200
plus your gasoline and that's the only
thing you're allowed to do
okay okay so let's pretend that that's 2
800
minus oh we'll even be generous 800
okay you have 800 expenses that's 2 000
2 000 pays off 10 000 how fast
at about five months there you go yeah i
i got a huge misconception about the
interest thing
it's very well the interest the interest
is brain damage for sure
but it's not going to hurt you as bad if
you pay it off in four or five months
i'd like for you to do it in four months
because i'd like you to have
zero expenses almost and just put 2500 a
month on there
i'd go get a third job and try to break
dave's record and try to do it even less
than that you are young
you've got plenty of time you ain't got
nothing to do but work yeah
now you got yourself a car that's paid
off and you're never gonna do this again
in fact
if you do what dave just said you're
gonna learn this lesson without too much
pain
yeah and you know if you learn this
lesson at 20 you never have to do it
again
that's the good news i've done a lot of
stupid stuff in my life sir
and the good news is if you if you when
you do something stupid if you just
never do that one again
there's plenty of other things you can
do to stupid but at least you never do
that one again
and if you don't do that one again
enough eventually people call you wise
that's true um so you went onto a car
lot and got screwed
what happened five percent you got
screwed by this company and
no one was there at 20 years old to
coach you and tell you you were getting
screwed that is absolutely
ridiculous you you paid too much for the
car
and you paid too much for the loan
you got there's nowhere in this whole
discussion that you got a deal
no one took care of you no one watched
out for you
your mom and dad just let you wander
down and get shot in the face
i mean this is bizarre okay
this is nuts so the bad news is you got
this lesson
the good news is it's a complete
thorough
butt kicking and you will remember it so
go make twenty five hundred to three
thousand dollars a month and pay these
crooks off
in the next four months and be done with
it